welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and James Gunn's sequel to Suicide
Squad titled Suicide Squad is apparently
underway after the full cast recently
met for a read-through in complete
secrecy I don't know how you get 15 cast
members in a room together without us
knowing but anytime Ruffalo farts the
whole world hears it but okay hip dates
we've heard about guns possible story
and cast our super interesting so let's
break down everything we know about this
next Suicide Squad film and spoiler
warning in case any this reveals too
much for you and that ruins your life
okay
first the title the Suicide Squad now
this doesn't mean the second film will
be a reboot of the 2016 film sounds like
it will be a sequel featuring many of
the same cast members margot robbie will
return as Harley Quinn Joel Kinnaman as
Rick Flagg Jai Courtney as Captain
Boomerang and Viola Davis as Amanda
Waller however this story will not
feature Will Smith as Deadshot or Jared
Leto as the Joker or any of the others
however the new cast being brought in is
insane James Gunn recently tweeted out
an image with the names of the full cast
including way where was he again Josh
you can never see that guy yeah John
Cena will be playing some role on this
cast I'm thinking you might be
peacemaker though I'm think there might
be another actor playing every role more
on that in a second we should
acknowledge that gun tweeted don't get
too attached hinting that many of these
characters could you know Slipknot style
die in the opening minutes and Cena
would be my pick for the first to go
also gun is bringing over his brother
Sean Gunn and Michael Rooker from his
guardians of the galaxy movies Idris
Elba has been cast some were thinking he
would be playing the new version of
Deathstroke recasting from the Joe
Manganiello version that we saw in the
Justice League post-credit scene elbow
was initially brought on to the film to
replace Will Smith as Deadshot but that
change he's gonna be playing a new
character however elbas character's
relationship with his daughter will
still be important she'll be played by
storm Reed Nathan Fillion has been cast
as well in a currently unknown role some
are speculating he might be playing
peacemaker a character who has been
reported to be in the movie peacemaker
is Christopher Smith an agent of peace
whose motives are driven by an extremist
form of pacifism that makes him love
peace so much he would kill for it and
to me that sounds like murder with more
steps Benicio del Toro will be playing a
villain character it sounds like with
rumors saying the name is something like
the mayor or the general comedian Steve
Agee will be playing King shark a
humanoid shark
the DC Comics whose father is thought to
be a so-called shark God others just
write them off as a British mutant David
decimal Chee and Kurt from the ant-man
movies will play polkadot man aka mister
polkadot he's a Batman enemy who grows
multicolored polka dots on his body that
he can turn the fireballs and other
weapons he's obviously super
self-conscious about his abilities
Daniela Melchior will play rat catchers
a gender swap version of the DC villain
Otis Flanagan a sanitation worker who
controls a legion of rats uses poison
gas and then there are other actors cast
an unknown roles like thor ragnarok
director and korg actor Taika Waititi
Flula Borg
Pete Davidson from SNL and Doctor Who
actor Peter Capaldi who said an
interview that he had to be completely
bald so they could apply some
prosthetics and filling out the cast our
Joaquin co-ceo mailing Oh Juan Diego
boto alice braga - not chica he see
julio ruiz and jennifer holland now
moving on to the rumored plot of james
gunn Suicide Squad but before we
continue thinking to privacy comm for
sponsoring this episode
privacy comm is a free service that lets
you buy things online using virtual
credit cards instead of your real credit
card information so that you can protect
yourself on the Internet essentially a
digital burner card with limits you
control and it's great you don't have to
worry about less than trustworthy
vendors using your card info to buy a
bunch of like explosive implants to keep
criminals focused on their suicide
missions yeah people in comic book
movies spend money and all kinds of
weird ways and so do people in the real
world with your card if you're not
careful also privacy calm lets you avoid
having to hand over the keys to your
finances every time you sign up for a
subscription to something because you
know they're just waiting to get you
before we have a chance to cancel that
subscription for example I set up an
account with privacy linked my bank
account had created a card specifically
for my monthly Netflix subscription
payment but for this virtual card I'm
setting the limit to just above my
$13.99 monthly subscription so if
someone tries to use his privacy card
number again or over target privacy will
notify you that they have blocked it
because the spending limit was already
reached see it's simple it's fast it's
really just one click and so easy and
again it's free we're gonna make this
deal even better for you guys first time
customers who sign up with privacy calm
slash new rock stars will get five
dollars off their first purchase with
privacy calm so go to privacy calm slash
new rock stars
that's priv Acy comm /n e wroc k st AR
as
to get $5 off your first purchase now
okay back to what we know about the plot
of guns these Suicide Squad the plot of
this sequel still a bit of a mystery but
with the 2016 Suicide Squad based
partially on the new 52 rent of the
comics there is some speculation that
James Gunn might be drawing on the 1980s
John Ostrander version of the comics
which was a bit more experimental
they're still trying to figure out the
voice of this lineup then the splashy
Harley driven one said the more recent
years the working title of this film is
El Dorado now El Dorado refers to the
mythical city of gold and the Spanish
Empire in South America in the 16th
century various expeditions throughout
the jungles of what is present-day
Colombia
if Benicio del Toro is playing a villain
called the mayor or the general maybe
the suicide mission that the crew is
being sent on involves like the
liberation of a Colombian city with del
Toro playing a Pablo Escobar type drug
kingpin or a corrupt military leader who
staged a coup and is now taking control
as a dictator and maybe this ragtag band
of criminals have to seek Redemption by
taking this guy down now this sounds a
bit like the plot of Fast Five I have no
problem with that it is the best Fast &
Furious movie and every movie should
look to it as an example that includes
Captain Boomerang dragging a safe
throughout the streets of the city James
Gunn has clarified that Batman will not
be in this story like the way he made a
cameo in the 2016 Suicide Squad so I
think it makes sense that this story is
not gonna be set in Gotham or any
American city but rather an
international mission and it might be
reading into the title a bit too much I
read into everything a bit too much but
by calling it V Suicide Squad that might
be kind of like a running theme or a
recurring joke with this group having a
chip on his shoulder to top the
successes of the previous generation of
the group and move out of their shadow
like maybe with this sequel in any
future Suicide Squad installments each
can debate over which crew is the
Suicide Squad what do you think James
Gunn means by this title comment down
below with your thoughts follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at a bus and
subscribed in a rockstars for more
theories about everything you love thank
you for joining me and let's just hope
that it yourself uh says the line would
is this some kind of the Suicide Squad
well it doesn't really work as well
[Music]